e andare incontro al futuro con la
determinazione non soltanto
quando di fuggire
vecchie
oggi sono estremamente contento di
quello che è successo anche perché si
parla di innovazione creatività e come
diceva ford se funziona e obsoleto
quindi vuol dire che siamo nel posto
giusto è il tema della creatività permea
questo questo ambiente no se se le cose
vanno come devono andare sono vecchie e
molto probabilmente quindi l'idea di ted
per me è una cosa straordinaria perché
condivide parente di condividere idee
condividere pensieri condivide di
permettere esperienze e il tema di oggi
è la la passione quello che mi è stato
così in qualche modo chiesto di
affrontare la passione per professione
io mi occupo di passione nel senso che
da molti anni sia con aziende che con
gruppi sportivi o altre situazioni o
team di alta performance il tema della
passione uno di quelli che emergono di
più oggi come oggi voi sapete che per
motivare no per trovare risultati nuovi
e proprio questa è la passione che si
usa la parola che si usa di più ora
quello che mi piacerebbe velocemente
affrontare è questa domanda dove deriva
la passione cos'è la passione quindi
parlarne più direttamente noi abbiamo
sentito storie di passione che
contengono passione però quello che
vorrei fare io cercare di fare una
riflessione su cosa è per davvero la
passione perché la cerchiamo in modo
così forte questa è una delle prime dei
primi e stimoli che arriva da funky
business e ci ricorda che purtroppo
siamo in un mondo che tende a omologarsi
e abbiamo sentito anche il mio collega
precedente raccontarsi di come si tende
a centralizzare ad omologare le
questioni siamo in una situazione in cui
abbiamo aziende simili con risorse umane
simili che hanno un'educazione simile
insomma troppa omologazione questa
omologazione porta ad abbassare il
valore delle cose quindi si cercano dei
picchi e questi picchi non possono
essere intercettati se non
elementi che hanno a che vedere con
l'innovazione
l'innovazione è un tema
straordinariamente interessante a volte
ci capita di costruire progetti
innovativi di avere richieste di
progetti innovativi e specialmente nel
mondo della interazione fra le persone
in aziende o in ambienti sportivi e più
portiamo innovazione più ci sentiamo
dire dai nostri interlocutori si ma chi
ha fatto già questa cosa
beh se l'innovazione e nessuno l'ha
fatta
e la risposta spesso è verve avessi
questo troppo innovativo qualcosa di un
po meno allora troppo innovativo è un
pochettino allucinate o e innovativo non
lo è cioè o nel nuovo o non lo è quindi
si cerca l'innovazione come strumento ma
a volte mi chiedo
abbiamo il coraggio poi di andare nel
nel nuovo e questa è una delle domande
che ci viene un pochettino risposta da
abbia otteniamo un po la risposta dalle
dottrine organizzative specialmente
questo è una delle dottrine fondamentali
dico perché si ricorda che nei primi
anni della produzione industriale spinta
non è la prima grande crescita dal 65 e
85 era pronti mirate fuoco c'era molto
tempo per fare le cose poi devono in 85
anni è stato a trasformarsi le cose le
velocità ha iniziato a cambiare abbiamo
iniziato a prendere veramente una spinta
molto molto forte e negli altri anni era
pronti fuoco mirate cioè intanto
spariamo poi dopo vediamo di controllare
non sono nati i missili intelligenti che
già è un ossimoro cioè missile
intelligente secondo me sono due cose
che non stanno insieme però ha detto i
missili intelligenti prima spariamo poi
decidiamo dove facciamo andare che è una
lucina già un'allucinazione degli esseri
umani
la terza situazione il fuoco fuoco fuoco
oggi non è che stai a pensare fa il
fuoco punto e basta
e questo indica no è poi il derivato di
quello che stiamo vivendo oggi la
tecnologia è vero che un grande
beneficio e contemporaneamente da una
velocità spaziale per la quale tempi e
spazi sono annullati proprio il
il mio collega precedentemente diceva
possiamo azzerare gli spazi anche nella
produzione di oggetti quindi è molto
interessante ma è molto veloce
questa porta a fare una trasporta una
trasformazione delle esigenze anche
organizzative aziendali che hanno che
nascono dall abbattimento dei costi
degli anni settanta cioè produciamo però
cerchiamo di abbattere i costi e quindi
profittare di più poi sono arrivati i
giapponesi con la qualità totale
dobbiamo dare qualità a qualsiasi
livello dell'organizzazione quindi una
sofisticazione ulteriore gli anni 90
sono stati gli anni del servizio e
quindi bisognava dare più contenuto di
servizio
se il millennio scorso vorrei dire è
stato quello in cui le soluzioni e le
esperienze la facevano da padrone noi
siamo il nuovo millennio
e oggi come oggi sembra che
l'orientamento più importante sia quello
della realizzazione dei sogni
realizzazione dei sogni in una parola
straordinaria e bellissima che però
indica la capacità di aprire un cassetto
e tirare fuori dei sogni e dare a quei
sogni un valore di questo vorrei parlare
quando parlo di passione per un motivo
molto semplice al di là della vostra
idea su dan brown
credo che questa almeno i bei libri che
ha scritto questa è la base kata dicendo
che creatività e passione sono il motore
dell'innovazione sono la guida
dell'innovazione quindi da una parte la
creatività e dall'altra la passione il
problema è che noi interpretiamo sempre
la passione come se fosse qualcosa di
interno cioè tutti quanti noi pensiamo
che la passione qualcosa di interno la
passione è un ponte che ci conduce al
nuovo ci porta in una dimensione nuova
se provate a fare una riflessione di
quella che è la vostra personalissima
esperienza sulle passioni
siamo sempre appassionati a qualcosa che
facciamo o qualcosa che vediamo o
qualcosa a cui tendiamo ma è difficile
avere una passione interna poter
ragionare questo qual è la tua passione
la nella mente corre scappa
all'esterno non all'inter non è stesse
no per passione io scala una montagna
per passione faccio il mio lavoro faccio
cose
l'innovazione è andare nel nuovo e la
passione quello che ci conduce nel nuovo
questo per una serie di motivi molto
semplici il primo deriva dal fatto che
crediamo che la passione sia quella cosa
che accende il nostro fare non è del
tutto vero questa una frase interessante
che mi ha detto una persona
personalmente non ho iniziato il mio
mestiere per passione ma perché era il
mio lavoro l'avevo scelto quello poi è
arrivata la passione un altro un'altra
persona che ho avuto la possibilità di
incontrare dio non ha iniziato ho
iniziato a nuotare perché odia vola
qualora mia madre per farmi lavare mi
portate in piscina perché non mi piace
allarmi e questo è un altra cosa
interessante un'altra frase che ho
sentito mia madre diceva che per fare
l'attore ci voleva studi e tanta
passione mica vero un ovale lo fa ora è
evidente che queste frasi non le
potremmo trovare e ricondurre le persone
che sono poco motivati e poco
appassionate e magari poco capace di
produrre risultati
leggendo le trovate no il germe della
della performance delle eccellenze in
realtà è così perché la prima mi è stato
detto da uno dei piloti della pattuglia
acrobatica nazionale è quindi uno che sa
volare dice davvero insomma nel senso
che per fare certe cose ce ne vuole
tanta di passione ma lui ha iniziato
senza la passione per lavoro poi dice
poi mi è piaciuto e adesso lo faccio
anche con intensità non è uno di quei
mediocri è uno dei migliori
claudio amendola detto questa cosa non è
che l'ha detto un perfetto sconosciuto e
addirittura per quanto riguarda l'acqua
umberto pellizzari personalmente
racconta sempre che lui era un po così
refrattario all'acqua iniziato andare in
piscina per questo motivo quindi persone
nelle quali noi intravediamo la passione
questo però non ha a che vedere con
il creare la passione io quando ho
cercato passione sul su internet la
prima cosa che si fa quando si fa una
conferenza si va su internet google
cerchi qualcosa da dire no di
interessante
ho scritto passione e quello che è
venuto fuori detto questo non posso
usare devo trovare nuove idee perché
sono immaginate possa essere uscito su
internet alla parola passione questo no
però il dizionario etimologico mi ha
aiutato la passione ha una sofferenza
fisica e spirituale e non sembra molto
produttivo questo quando una parte da lì
la passione la passione di cristo non si
riconduce oggi la pensiamo comunque cosa
di bello ma la passione qualcosa che
permette anche una sofferenza
perturbazione affezione soffrire subire
e sopportare nulla di buono con cui da
un lato la sofferenza dalla dall'altro i
moti irrazionali e concupiscenti
dell'animo umano
qua ho detto c'è luce in fondo al tunnel
se per effetto della crisi energetica
non la spengono e meglio però c'è
qualcosa di buono perché la passione e
anche qualcosa di buono ma specialmente
la passione contiene due dimensioni
fondamentali da una parte la passione è
il piacere il provare piacere godimento
in qualche modo quindi qualcosa che ci
attrae e dall'altra il dolore queste due
facce della parola passione sono due
elementi centrali per creare movimento
per uscire da una normalità che è il
nostro conformano delle cose che
noi dobbiamo sempre ricordare che noi
siamo progettati per conservare energia
per stare nella nostra area di confort
non fare troppa fatica e magari un po
noioso
però insomma non abbiamo preoccupazione
da questo punto di vista fuori dal
confort ci sono le cose che sappiamo
fare bene e vengono definite aree di
performance spesso e volentieri quando
si parla di passione si dice se mi
appassioni miei danno performance
migliori no se ti appassioni tuoi non
danno performance migliori di persona i
tuoi fanno cose diverse
cioè la questo sconosciuto tutto quello
che fin qua ho descritto l'area di
comfort e le performance sono quelle che
fanno parte le cose che noi sappiamo già
fare che conosciamo e fuori da qua che
succedono le cose magiche dove ci sono
le aree l'area di crescita come viene
definita si entra nel nuovo in area di
crescita il problema che le persone
tendono a non andare in aree di crescita
perché hanno paura di fare brutta figura
perché si sbaglia quando si fanno cose
nuove si sbaglia quando si inizia è una
manifestazione nuova notte se ne frega
sbagliamo però intanto facciamo delle
cose e questa è una cosa importante
fuori dal kof orci al panico quindi
bisognerebbe sempre avere un discreto
equilibrio ci andiamo fuori ma non
troppo
questo è il motivo per cui ci crei
chiedono progetti innovativi ma non
troppo perché sennò è pericoloso insomma
questa è abbastanza comprensibile ora il
piacere e il dolore sono due cose legate
perché genera una sensazione da una
parte di volontà e dall'altra di dovere
ecco che la passione diventa un motore
forte perché volere e dovere sono
collegati lo voglio e devo farlo in
qualche modo o un moto anche esterno che
mi obbliga mi spinge mi induce a fare
cose
il problema è che la passione attraverso
la quale noi riusciamo a portare le
persone fuori dall'orario di confort
questi i grandi allenatori no utilizzano
questa idea ti porto a far qualcosa di
nuovo per sviluppare le performance i
manager nelle aziende hanno la
responsabilità di fare questo il
problema è che la passione non si
attacca la passione soggettiva è una
cosa che collega la nostra idea di
piacere con con l'esterno ma non si
attacca allora bisognerebbe fare un
ragionamento un po diverso
e bisognerebbe ragionare sul termine
entusiasmo eccole la scintilla della
passione
entusiasmo l'entusiasmo intanto se
andate su google
scrivete entusiasmo escono cose molto
più positive ma non c'entra niente
questo sul dizionario etimologico
l'entusiasmo smaschera un significato
straordinario intensa partecipazione
esaltazione addirittura se scendiamo in
profondità il dio che c'è in noi in
qualche modo quindi un'idea di come
posso dire proprio deo all'interno dei
nostri delle nostre volontà i nostri
sogni che accendono la passione
entusiasmo e una parola meravigliosa
perché ha caratteristiche diverse dalla
passione perché oltre che accendere la
nostra passione ha la caratteristica di
essere estremamente diffondibile
divulgabile semi entusiasmo tendo a
riuscire ad entusiasmare questo alberto
bucci che sostiene sempre che la
passione come l'influenza
se c'era il attacchi è come un virus
però ce la devi avere se non ce l'hai
non non riesce attacca non puoi far
finta di essere entusiasta devi esserlo
ecco che l'entusiasmo muove questo
questa volontà di entrare in contatto
con noi stessi e ci permette di ottenere
dei risultati
l'entusiasmo deriva dalla volontà di
accettare il nostro sogno di aprire un
cassetto dei sogni e determinare noi
stessi come realizzazioni realizzatori
nei nostri sogni
questa è già una cosa difficile la
maggior parte delle persone non
accettano di prendere in considerazione
la possibilità di realizzare un sogno
perché perché è necessario fare qualcosa
di nuovo
questo è il motivo per cui la passione
da sola non basta perché una parte più
emotiva e nemmeno probabilmente il sogno
bisogna scegliere di fare cose anche
rischiando anche sbagliando simone moro
uno degli scalatori estremi sostiene che
un sogno grande ha bisogno di gambe
forti e dare gambe un sogno è una delle
cose più importanti che noi possiamo
fare da lì che nasce l'entusiasmo che
accende la passione in realtà del
coraggio di dare gambe un sogno quindi
anche fare gli errori che
sono previsti quindi immaginate la
passione come un collante fra tre
dimensioni la prima dimensione le
mozioni d'entusiasmo quindi la parte più
emotiva
dall'altra una parte più se vogliamo di
competenza di capacità di fare le cose
perché non basta immaginare di fare
qualcosa ma è necessario poi entrare nel
merito della capacità di realizzare
queste cose e per terza dimensione
il fatto di dare gambe a questo sogno
ecco la passione dal mio punto di vista
è un luogo magico lì in mezzo fra l'over
l'app di queste tre dimensioni
bisognerebbe sempre cercare di
intercettarlo così perché amo dire che
le persone per passione fanno anche cose
molto stupide mettere insieme alle tre
cose rende la passione è veramente un
grandissimo acceleratore ora non voglio
proseguire oltre perché giustamente il
modello ted prevede che ho ancora 40
secondi di tempo per ricordarvi che vale
la pena aprire un cassetto dei sogni
rovesciarli su un tavolo fare pulizia di
quelli che magari sono meno importanti e
rilevanti per noi scegliere uno tenerlo
fuori ogni giorno guardarli in faccia
senza nasconderlo e provare a
realizzarlo perché era proprio philippe
petit uno dei più incredibili ispiratori
della politica moderna
l'uomo che ha attraversato le due torri
camminando su un filo che amava dire che
i limiti esistono solo nell'animo di chi
è a corto dei sogni e quindi il mio
augurio per voi che tirate fuori vostro
sogno è che lydiate gambe forti
grazie simone è un complimento